basketball live star Brooke Bailey is
mourning the death of her daughter Kayla
Bailey the 45 year old took to Instagram
on Sunday to share pics of her daughter
revealing the 25 year old's tragic death
in the caption quote forever my baby
pretty black aka Kayla Nicole Bailey
this is not a goodbye mommy will see you
soon the cause of Kayla's death has not
been released however Brooke did repost
an article from a Basketball Wives fan
account that claimed Kayla died
following a car accident on Sunday in
Memphis the reality star continued to
honor her late daughter on her insta
story writing quote Kayla left a mark on
so many lives she entered the room and
demanded respect love and attention if
you had the pleasure of meeting her and
being friends with her she has forever
changed your life Brooke's post was
flooded with prayers from fans and
celebs alike with stars like Nicki Minaj
and Porsche Williams sharing their
condolences and Brooke's fellow
Basketball Wives star Evelyn Lozada
shared a touching message Brooke I can't
imagine the pain you're going through
during this difficult time I'm so sorry
for your loss Brooke who had
relationships with former NBA stars
Rashad Lewis and Vernon Macklin made her
first appearance on Basketball Wives in
2012. at the end of the day no one wants
to work with the diva no one wants to be
bothered with someone that's coming to
work with a bad attitude Brooke first
appeared on season two and later
returned to the show in its 10th season
which premiered this past may I
definitely feel like I knocked it out
the ballpark Brooke also changed her bio
on Instagram paying tribute to her
daughter writing quote forever Kayla
Nicole Bailey
3297
925-22 hashtag pretty black
foreign
[Music]